let's start about talking about
convolutional neural networks again a
few people have been asking what do the
convolutional layers look like so you
know what transformations are happening
on these input images that mean we can
do something interesting in terms of
machine learning so what I've done is
I've trained up a pretty basic network
to do digit recognition and so we can
see what the convolutions are doing what
the intermediate layers look like and
then hopefully what the classification
is at the end so people get a good idea
let's start talking about em mist
so--even East is a data set that was has
been around for a few years and was
produced by Anakin who is I think
currently at Facebook and is big in deep
learning and loads of good papers and
one of his early efforts into
convolutional neural networks was
Lynette is or what we call it which was
a sort of five layer ish small
convolutional neural network aimed at
doing this m-miss data set and it
basically said look this convolutional
neural network is going to be really
good on digit recognition the current
state of the art is all these machine
learning techniques and now we're even
better than that so what I've done is
I've tweaked the Lynette model a bit to
make it a little bit more interesting
and then I basically printed out all the
intermediate layers so we can see them
on a few digits so you can see how it
works this is live that's right just
four digits naught to nine in fact it's
it's small 28 pixel by 28 pixel images
of any handwritten digits naught to 9
and there's about I think 90,000 also
imitated data sets so there's about
10,000 for testing and about 80,000 for
training the normal linear network is I
think a convolutional layer followed by
a pooling sort of that spatial down
sampling layer followed by another
convolution followed by another spatial
down sampling and all this kind of thing
now the thing about spatial down
sampling is it's useful in some
situations but it's not very interesting
to look at because we're then looking at
images that are just really really small
so what I've done is I've done away with
that and I've just put in loads more
convolutional layers so my network is I
think if I refer back to my 1/2
the evil five six is six convolutional
layers apparently according to my piece
of paper and then two fully connected
artificial neural network layers at the
end so I was going to write these down
so we've got one two three four five six
convolutional layers all of which have
five by five kernels so this isn't the
standard Network this is just one that
came up with myself on this digit
recognition task any reasonable network
will probably do a pretty good job you
know if you've thought a little bit
about it because it's just not in a
digit recognition is not quite as hard
as character recognition which in turn
is not as hard as other problems and so
on so just purely because there are less
digits yeah there is less there's
basically less variation between images
if you're if you're taking lots of
pictures of cats and lots of pictures of
dogs there's going to be more variation
over the image and more pixels to deal
with than there is in a 28 by 28 picture
but may have a nine in it or it may have
a slight different shape nine you know
and then I've got my fully connected
layer so I'm going to say F c1 and when
I've got a fully connected layer here FC
2 FC 1 has an output size of 500
according to my piece of paper
I've forgotten already and FC 2 has an
output size of 10 which is the digits
right so if we think back to our last
video on convolutional networks after
we've done all our convolutions we have
some fully connected layers which
actually perform the classification and
the last fully connected layer in this
case is going to be however long we have
different classes so we have ten classes
0 2 all the way to 9 so 10 outputs and
when output number 2 lights up or
produces a high value that means the
digit 1 which is slightly confusing with
zero index but digit 1 has been
recognized ok so I won't go into too
much detail about what effect each of
these will have on the input image but
you can imagine that if you've got a 28
by 28 image input then this first
convolutional layer which is 5 by 5 is
going to reduce the width of that and
the height of that image by 4 because
you know it's not going to go right to
the edges and we're not doing any
padding so you're going to then have a
24 by 24 image and then the next layer
will take it down to 20 by 20 and the
next layer will take it down further
than that so let's talk about
many feet how many different kernels I
have at each of these layers so the
first layers I've got 20 different
kernels per layer and then if I refer
back to my model file is that the code
it's actually a text document in cafe
because this is the library I've been
using to do this which basically
explains is where you detail with what
size of kernels how many kernels how
many layers you have which ones connect
to which other ones and so on okay this
is obviously slightly different to the
stock emne Smolin file but it's no
similar stuff okay so for example if we
pick a layout random can you see this
layer here so we've got 20 outputs
kernel size a 5 asteroid of 1 and then
this tells you how you're going to
randomize your weight when you begin
training okay so we just describe all of
these things to the network and it goes
off and does most of the work for us
so my first two layers of 20 kernels
then because I decided this was a good
idea I increase this number to 50
kernels 50 kernels and I have 450
kernels you can imagine that your input
image to begin with is 28 by 28 and it's
1 deep because we have a grayscale image
these are grayscale digits we're looking
at here after the first 5x5 convolution
this image is going to shrink to 24 by
24 but because there's 20 different
kernels all producing their own image
output it's going to be 24 by 24 by 20
and so on okay I won't draw the whole
thing out because we've done that in the
last video but these convolutions here
because I'm not using any padding will
slowly decrease the size of the image
and when it gets to this point here at
the first fully connected layer the
image should be 4 by 4 by 50 deep which
is 800 different values now often we
would go right down to 1 1 but that is
not really necessary in this case
because it's not too much data so this
first full of connected layer is five
hundred neurons long all of which
connect to all of a different possible
possible 800 values and then the final
ten come from this 500 so let's look at
some pictures and then maybe it'll be
more clear ok it's not a very
complicated network modern networks get
much bigger than this but this shows you
the kind of thing that they're doing so
I've printed out some examples of the
kind of things that these net
will do so let's just use number two as
an example this is a picture of a two
all right very exciting for everyone
watching it's a 28 by 28 picture over to
which has been normalized so but it's
it's the background is basically black
and the foreground is white okay you get
slightly better results if you normalize
because your face press lightly with
their pen and maybe not done a very firm
- then maybe you sort of increase the
contrast a little bit so we're first
going to do a 5x5 convolution over this
and we're going to do 20 of those so
unsurprisingly if we first move this
away we're going to see a number of
kernel convolutions these are performing
low-level image processing tasks just
like the kind of Sobel edge detector
that I talked about in previous videos
so this one for example is a kind of
diagonal gradient you can see that the
edges for going diagonally are quite
highlighted and then there's different
orientations so this one's horizontal
and there's a vertical one sort of here
and so on we can't do a lot of
interesting things with this image after
just one set of convolutions but we're
getting there so this one is starting to
be transformed some of them are noisier
than others that's partly due to my you
know not having trained it very long and
partly because maybe that's useful so
we're going to do another set of
convolutions on all of these inputs so
these are now going to be convolutions
of convolution it starting to get a
little bit smoother because we're
shrinking our image down and we're
slowly starting to find higher-level
features so now you can see that the
loop in the top of the two has been
highlighted here and this one is
highlighted only the horizontal bit on
the top of the bottom of the two that
kind of makes sense so different areas
of the image are now starting to be
highlighted we're bringing in different
information and as we keep going you can
see we're going even further so we've
increased the number of features and you
can kind of see maybe there was used to
be a 2 there but we've extracted away
the actual 2 now and we're looking just
at features so there's lots of diagonals
here which have been highlighted and
they're highlighted in very specific
newer ones because some of them are
looking for some things and some of them
are looking for other things just by
looking at these pictures it's hard to
know exactly what each of these is
looking for because they'd be looking
for something different if you had a
different number in there we keep going
and they get smaller and smaller and
they get more and more abstract so
you're still seeing the tip of a 2 here
and this is the right-hand side of the
image highlighted things that the
computer thinks are useful
learn that tell us about what it is to
be a to which is a kind of weird concept
right and we keep going and the images
continue to just get smaller and smaller
until we get to our final four by four
images now I'll put a comparison of two
different digits up on these in a minute
but you can see that obviously we're
getting very general shapes now there's
no concept of a two anymore this has
been completely extracted away into
which of these are lit up and we're and
we connect that to our first fully
connected layer which I've tried to
print out but it's kind of odd which is
just a bunch of activation spread out
over these five hundred not all of them
are activated as you can see the white
ones are very strong activations the
gray ones are in the middle and the
black ones are very low activations so
you can see that you know these two are
good so in some sense it's learned that
when there's a two in the image these
two are going to light up and so this
one and so on basically I've said here
the picture of a two I'd like you to
output the number two and it said well
okay if I make these like this then
that's what works so it's just following
a mathematical process so even for
different imaging to that those two they
will be yeah they will be subtly
different I mean if you've got a really
well-trained algorithm needs to start to
look very similar but there's a lot of
newer ones here and there's only ten
classes so there's going to be more
information in here in some way than you
need and then at the end this is a
little bit practice a little bit easier
to understand these are our final ten
outputs these two are not real I've just
they're just left in from by mistake
when I've been printing so you can see
zero one two the white one the one
that's lit up is number two okay so this
is essentially correctly identified at
two now obviously in my program I would
read this value out and do something
useful with it I wouldn't just print it
as a block but you get the idea okay
let's have a look at two versus let's
say some other number four is kind of
likely to in a sense that it has some
sort of horizontal bits in it although
actually that's true of any digit so
really it falls nothing like a two I'm
talking nonsense the first layer looks
much like the one from the two right
because it would do because we've only
done one set of convolutions and they
all do much the same thing so you can
see that for example in this one here
you've got mostly these kind of corners
here but it highlighted and that's true
of the four as well as we've sort of
progressed it and I'll skip a few layers
let's see if I can get the matching
layer from the four you can see that
some elements are the same and some are
different so this one here this new one
here is darker but it's got a white
region that
in this too okay so this one's starting
to pick up differences between these two
images now and you know if you studied
these for a while you could see there's
some other differences again I'm showing
you this because it's interesting to see
what a convolutional neural network does
but it's very difficult to look at this
and go oh of course this is finding all
the corners of the four here and so on
you'd have to study it for quite a long
time to work out what what that is there
are people doing these sort of things
but to be honest most people will just
go us you know nice and it works and
that's what's important so as we
progress a bit further so this is the
last convolutional output before fully
connected layers now you can see that
actually there are some quite big
differences so this one for example is
bright in the top left and dark in the
top right for the four whereas it's dark
in the top left and right and the bottom
right for two at this point we've now
extracted away anything but said exactly
what the image looked like and now we're
looking just at features so these are
basically things that the computer finds
useful and now they're completely
different and as we now look at the
fully connected layers completely
different neurons have been activated
these two are now dark and there's some
white ones in this four that aren't in
this one and so on
so what it's done is its transformed the
image using a convolutional layers into
something that when it gets to the fully
connected layer looks different to the
computer and that's really useful
and then finally unsurprisingly number
fours it up all right so it's
successfully worked and that's basically
what it looks like now obviously if you
have a much deeper convolutional network
with many more classes this is going to
be doing lots of more hierarchical
complex operations but this is basically
the gist of what a convolutional net
what we'll do
don't take for you to do well building
the model took a few minutes and then I
had trained it was a few hours because
I've added a few convolutional layers it
takes you know 40 minutes to train a
most if you're doing a standard small
Network which still is 98% accurate on
these on these digits and how much
harder is it to do for say letters it's
a bit harder because you've got 26
classes instead of all maybe four
capitals as well you've got even more
classes but on the other hand it's if
you if you're proof if you're providing
images like this which are very
controlled it's not very difficult if
you're producing any
possible a then it's going to be more
challenging but still convolutional
networks can do these tasks quite easily
you just have to increase the number of
convolutions increase the number of
Colonels who have put layer just to
increase the amount that it can do and
then you just leave it to train a bit
longer when it seems to work this I mean
this seems to me that all these things
we see on websites these days where it
says are you a human click this button
yeah kind of a thing of the past then
are there captures yeah so in some sense
this the old capture style that we had
where you would see like five or six
letters and have to tie them in they are
defeated by convolutional neural
networks if someone has bothered to
train a convolutional neural network to
defeat that task one important thing to
remember is that I've trained this
network on a very specific set of digits
if I give it some kind of capture with
digits in particularly if it's more than
one digit per image it doesn't not going
to understand because I've been giving
it 28 by 28 images with just one digit
in so to get to work on a specific
capture system you're going to have to
train it on that specific capture system
now one of the nice things that capture
systems do from the point of view of
trying to crack them is generate a lot
of images so you just download their API
and you can just generate data set after
data set so in some sense image based
captures are starting to look a bit weak
on the other hand as a researcher I'm
not inherently interested in breaking
capture I think it's probably first
quite useful purpose so you know maybe a
spammers trying to do this so you start
to look it to more complex capture
systems so for example Google's
recapture which won't necessarily
provide you with numbers will ask you
can you see all the biscuits in this
image and you'll see a 9x9 grid of
biscuits and then it's it's slightly
more complicated for a bot to interact
with this HTML and it's a slightly more
complicated problem particularly if you
don't know what it's going to ask until
it does so I guess the idea is to keep
changing your capture system with enough
frequency that if anyone had trained a
network to solve it it then becomes
redundant and they can't solve a next
one
you
is that if I obtain a cookie of you
which is supposed to be secure then I
can send that to let's say Amazon or to
a shop and say I'm sure and please you
know what's in a shopping basket what's
his address
what's his credit card details